como todas las mañanas reina la
incertidumbre y es que por ejemplo esta
noche nos han escrito desde la minga
para decirnos que en puerto resistencia
donde ha estado este equipo se
produjeron disparos en la noche de ayer
así que como todas las mañanas
esclarecer los hechos está resultando
difícil lo que sí que se ha podido
esclarecer es que ayer durante el día
nuestro equipo estaba grabando y
escuchamos disparos luego pudimos saber
que fue un camión del que bajaron
aparentes civiles que dispararon contra
manifestantes después los manifestantes
se dirigieron hacia el camión y
encontraron prendas polis policiales la
policía ha reconocido que ellos
participaron en ese operativo y que el
operativo era para levantar los retenes
que se están produciendo en la ciudad y
que los manifestantes les habían atacado
hiriendo a dos policías sin embargo
desde los manifestantes dicen que los
policías los que recibieron las balas
fueron por el ejército una unidad del
ejército que estaba allá y que custodió
a los propios manifestantes así que una
situación un poco confusa
cabe destacar que respecto a estos
bloqueos nuestro equipo también ayer don
decidió ir a una plaza de mercado para
conocer cómo son los ánimos de la
población y realmente la población nos
mostró más el dedo
hacia el gobierno que no hacía los
manifestantes